[Music]
you know i spent this july 4th at a lake
house
drinking beer eating copious amounts of
meat watching unsanctioned and arguably
unsafe fireworks displays put on by
different houses around the lake at one
point someone's firework misfired
and a ball of flame descended gracefully
from the sky
and landed directly on the roof of the
house next door
unfortunately it was slightly raining at
this point so no fires were started
though the guy who owned the house
was not amused for some reason my point
is simply that
i just like so many of you celebrated
the holiday the way that it was meant to
be celebrated patriotically and joyfully
and gluttonously and gratuitously and
stupidly
but july 4th for many other americans is
not a time for something so frivolous as
happiness
it is rather a time for anger and sorrow
these are the americans who profess to
hate this country though they
choose to still live here gorging
themselves on the bounty of western
civilization while bitterly complaining
about the people
who provided that bounty to them most of
these ungrateful whiny losers can't even
really explain
why they hate this country so much as
this recent video from campus reform
demonstrates are you proud to be an
american
no i feel embarrassed to be an american
every day
um not really in this climate no like
i'm a black person so obviously i
experience a lot of
uh you know there's like oppression that
comes with that
um not most of the time i think
sometimes it's just a little
embarrassing
you know be proud of what and what is
there to be proud about if you're black
and being like you know because it's
just like it's a
still a lot of stuff that goes on for
black people i think that's a
complicated question for me i think i
i i think most of the time no
at least over like the past four years
it's been tricky to
you know love to be an american well
like america sucks you know because like
it oppresses black people or whatever
how does it oppress them what is the
exact nature of this oppression
that's never explained the people who
hate america are like sullen teenagers
who go around complaining that their
lives are so difficult
and miserable even as they enjoy the
easiest and most painless existence
that the world can possibly offer to a
human being in fact those same sullen
teenagers crying that they're being
oppressed by their parents because they
aren't allowed to stay out until 1am on
a school night or whatever it is
often grow up and turn into the sorts of
adults who cry that they're being
oppressed by society or systemic racism
or the patriarchy
for reasons that are even more
superfluous july 4th has now become an
occasion
for such people to air their grievances
and while this is annoying and pathetic
it's also illuminating because in airing
their grievances you're able to see
just how stupid are those grievances and
how hypocritical and also stupid
are the ones airing them so here's one
representative example that is worth i
think some special attention
this comes from a twitter account called
lakotaman
his bio tells us that he has a ba in
sociology
you perhaps can already guess where this
is headed simply based on the fact that
this is the kind of guy
who brags about having a bachelor's
degree in sociology
on july 4th lakota man ba tweeted this
he says
hey america fu for desecrating our
sacred mountain
hashtag happy fourth and it's
accompanied by a picture of presumably
himself
and two other people pointing their
middle fingers at mount rushmore
now many questions potentially arise
questions like
what sort of person drives all the way
out to mount rushmore just to flip off a
bunch of rocks
i guess it kind of reminds me of the
time when i drove four hours to the
beach
in order to scream at a mound of sand
it's really annoying when sand gets in
your shoes
and i just thought it was time that
someone finally sent the message
but in any case more to the point let's
consider the specific complaint that
lakota man b.a has here
he says that america has desecrated his
sacred mountain the black hills
by carving the mount rushmore sculpture
into it
he also says in subsequent tweets that
this was
land theft and colonization etc
now this claim of land theft made by
modern native americans
is almost always species and
hypocritical but when it's made by
someone descended from the lakota tribe
about the black hills
the irony is even more pronounced lakota
man b.a says that his
people owned the black hills it was
sacred to them
the white man ruthlessly stole and
desecrated the land that belonged to
them
but does that mean that the lakota were
the first to inhabit this region of the
country
no far from it before the lakota the
black holes were
occupied by the arapaho in fact the
chain of possession during recorded
history goes back to the 16th century
and during that time the land was
claimed by the arapaho kiowa crow
cheyenne
and arikara tribes before we got to the
um
to the lakota and that's only recorded
history
archaeologists tell us that the very
very first occupants of this region
were called the clovis people about 13
000 years
ago well archaeologists did tell us that
now we're told that the clovis people
came somewhat more recently and they're
predated by another group of people who
we know very little about
the point is that the black hills his
sacred mountains
are not his at all his people were not
the first to occupy it not the second
not the third not the fourth not the
fifth not the sixth
indeed the lakota came in the 19th
century moved everyone else out took
over and immediately
declared the mountains sacred to them
like they just got there killed a bunch
of people and said
these mountains are sacred keep
something in mind here
when we say that one tribe moved other
tribes out of the region
we don't mean that they asked them to
politely to leave
okay they didn't show up with a with a
with a note
and say well would you hey guys would
you mind skedaddling here
would you would you mind moving over and
giving up some space would you mind
that's not how it worked in indian
culture war over land
was very common and it was very
very brutal slaughter decapitation
dismemberment rape enslavement
scalping were all common features of
these conflicts
speaking of scalping the earliest the
earliest evidence that we have of this
practice to my knowledge
dates to the 14th century in south
dakota
a mass grave from that period has been
uncovered and we don't know exactly what
happened
but whatever happened it's been dubbed
the crow creek massacre because the
human
remains show that hundreds of people
were cut to pieces scalped tortured
mutilated
and this is before any white man had set
foot on that part of the globe
way before which means that um that that
one native american tribe did that to
another
and there's nothing especially
surprising about that
that's how they treated each other and
that's what they did when they wanted to
take the land
occupied by some other group
now bringing this back to the black
hills one indian tribe conquered and
massacred another tribe for access to
that land and then that tribe was
conquered and massacred by another and
so on and so until finally
not but a century or so before the white
man showed up the lakota came and did
the same
stealing the land from the thieves that
had most recently stealing stolen it
before them
then a short time later in the grand
scheme of things the us government rolls
in and a series of battles are fought
over those mountains called the black
hills war
and the u.s won the battle that is
the u.s conquered the people who had
most recently
conquered the land we're left then with
the with the original question
who owns that land
if you say that conquest is illegitimate
and it's always wrong to conquer land
and overthrow the people occupying it
then you can't say that the the lakota
own it because they did the same
and you can't say that the cheyenne own
it or the acaira or the co
the kiowa so who owns it
who's the victim of this theft the
clovis people
with their stone tools 13 000 years ago
maybe we should find some of them and
apologize
but they weren't there first either they
somehow came to supplant some other
stone age people before them and i can
pretty much guarantee you
that that supplanting was not peaceful
very few things were at that point in
our history
this is the absurd rabbit hole that you
fall down whenever you try to claim that
the u.s
stole the land it currently occupies in
order for a thing to be stolen it must
first be owned
but if you say that the most recent
indian tribe who lived on it owned it
then you're legitimizing conquest and if
you legitimize conquest
then there's no reason why the united
states conquest
should not be considered legitimate
as i've argued many times conquest was
the way of the world
all over the world everywhere among all
people for thousands of years
if you wanted it you took it
if you wanted to keep it you defended it
if you couldn't defend it you lost it
if you couldn't take it you didn't get
it as simple as that
america didn't invent this concept we
didn't even practice the most brutal
form of it not even close
today we're simply blamed because we
were better at it
americans played the exact same game the
indians played
they observed the exact same rule of
conquest a brutal rule but a universal
one
and they were just better at it they won
and now we're supposed to be ashamed of
that victory and weep over it and
apologize
centuries later but apologize to who
the conquerors who were conquered the
thieves who had their stolen goods
stolen
that's absurd i for one apologize for
nothing
and i'm ashamed of nothing and i'm happy
that america is here and i'm happy that
it won that conflict in that war
i'm happy that this civilization is here
i would rather live in this civilization
and i think everyone would including the
lakota man ba
but anyone who is ashamed of america is
free to leave
and on the way out please just know that
you are of course
cancelled well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content